trois feux qui débutera à 18h pour tout
le monde dès samedi et pour au moins
minimum 15 jours à compter de lundi tous
les voyageurs en provenance de pays hors
union européenne devront présenter un
test négatif de -2 72 heures et s'isoler
pendant sept jours
les établissements scolaires maintenu
ouvert janvier enfin voilà et enfin
pouvait le faire mais si vous y allez
les cherry et voilà et donc voilà ce
qu'il a dit bon c'est tout voilà c'est
tout ce qu'on peut en plo résumé c'est
ça bah oui et dans la région ils vont
tout faire mais vous pensez vous êtes
toujours de bonne humeur
cc c'est une évidence non il n'y a pas
de raison que la france échappe à ce que
s'est passé partout en europe et dans
d'autres pays
l'idée bien que dans quinze jours des
cadres augmentés et qui rompt oublié de
fermer la valve or 15 jours un mois
c'est énorme et c'est ce qui se dit en
tous les cas d'autant plus que le vario
anglais ils ont dit circulation qu'à
part de 200 à 300 cas par jour expose en
tout cas pour l'instant qu'un jour je
vous le dis de couvre-feu à 18 heures
tout le monde à la maison souvient marc
montiel voilà oui alors le président de
la région
les républicains et les papilles
rayonnement jean rottner g sud est il a
reconnu quand même que le couvre feu
était très profitable parce que du coup
ça avait descendu les chiffres donc oui
on sait c'est le taux d'incidence est
lui bientôt il va être au point aux
points joués à ce texte
le pas du gouvernement c'est un modèle
républicain c'est pas moi ouais c'est
bon vous connais merci oui je compte me
oui la question je me pose sur le pauvre
faut déjà que l'efficacité contrairement
à ce que dit bernard on n'est pas
vraiment sûr de ça est-ce que l'avancé
de deux heures ça va réellement changer
les souris la sociologie est ce que ça
va changer c'est que ça va être un drame
pour l'économie mais vous et vous vous
servez vous êtes toujours en rapport et
non mais c'est tout et laisse le plus
jeune de la table c'est le mec le
magasin est fermé à 5h30 on pourra plus
rien faire et en plus avec les merdes
que vous sachiez je pense que c'est une
bonne idée c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour vous le recul guillaume on
met à 16 portant de taux d'incidence 43%
pour mercy arlette chabot non je sais où
vous croyez chivot mais il ya comme un
point ultra positif c'est qu'ils ont
voulu sauver l'école bien sûr parce qu
on a fait quand même se retrouver ont
commencé à parler depuis quelques jours
des white cantine si on veut sauver win
your way non mais non mais hormis cela
sauver l'école c'est aussi sauver une
partie de l'emploi parce que je sais à
voir ses enfants au quotidien et ça
c'est bien de tenter castaldi là le
l'oiseau de mauvais augure qui dictent
par jour on va être confiné merci si
vous préoccupez vous de votre on va
continuer merci et vous savez qu'on à
l'antenne la saison n'est prêt à manger
une citronnade avec une gousse coutouly
delphine wespiser vient d'appeler peu de
beauté sous peu
autre fait à 18 heures ça se fait depuis
plusieurs semaines chez nous dans le
grand test alors niveau organisation
c'est un peu timing parce qu'à partir de
17h30 faut penser à rentrer mais en tout
cas dans le grand test ça s'est
stabilisé donc ça veut dire ça
fonctionne et c'est faisable et c'est
vivable
bon ça change pas grand chose david
suffit